we began with very sad news from
California where a traffic stop turned
into a gun battle that killed a highway
patrol officer last night witnesses say
that a man grabbed a rifle from his
pickup truck in Riverside and just
started shooting while the officer was
filling out paperwork to impound the
vehicle the gunman was also killed two
other officers were wounded as Carter
Evans reports passers-by were caught up
in the gunfire
Gabriela Mendoza watched in horror as a
gunman dressed in black holding what
appears to be an assault-style rifle
began firing at officers just off
Interstate 215 the man was just shooting
just to shoot he looked like he had
experience with the video shows a
wounded officer being rushed away in a
police Carter in the shootout the
officer who conducted the traffic stop
Andre Moy was airlifted to the hospital
he died from his injuries unbelievable
this is so unbelievable who does this
kind of stuff drivers along the busy
freeway were caught in the crossfire
including Jennifer Moctezuma who was
driving her six-year-old twins home when
a bullet hit our car it hit straight in
the middle of my windshield missing my
head and my two children that were in
the backseat
retired Marine Charles Childress was in
the car behind them heard the kids
screaming and quickly pulled the family
to safety ricocheted bullets are still
firing so I took the kids out and her
out and I put him behind the engine
block of her car for protection yeah I'm
just I'm so just thankful that Chuck
came to save us because or else we still
would have been in the car duct and not
knowing what to do he's honestly a hero
hours later officers lined the streets
to salute officer Moy for his nearly
three years on the force for CBS this
morning Carter Evans Los Angeles
authorities expect the other two wounded
officers to survive they have not yet
confirmed the gunman's identity and
still do not know where he was heading
or why he turned on the officers